hey guys anna welcome back to the leia hill fan
show this particular episode is sponsored by
exodus wallet so a huge thank you to exodus wallet
because without them we wouldn't be able to bring
you such brilliant content so exodus wallet
is a next generation digital marketplace and
cryptocurrency wallet it's available on desktop
it's available on mobile it's also available on
iphone android it's easy to use easy to download
and to be honest is my number one top pick when
it comes to cryptocurrency wallets joining me
today is the one and only mayor of miami frances
suarez frances how are you i'm wonderful thank you
so much it's great to have you thank you so much
for joining me miami is a really interesting
place i've been here for about two months now
and the first thing that i noticed as soon as i
arrived was the intense entrepreneurial spirit
everybody is building there's so much innovation
and it's quite unprecedented given the times
we're living in so firstly i just want to start by
saying thank you essentially for allowing um this
this environment to flourish well i appreciate it
and you're right you know we do we are extremely
entrepreneurial what's changed is that you know
we used to be sort of a small business mecca
and that's great that's wonderful because small
business powers this country empowers the world
but i think now we've learned the power of
scale and i think that makes us dangerous
right in the sense that we have the ability now
to tap into what other big markets across the
world have tapped into which is the ability to
to start something and make it something that's
ubiquitous that's that's used and that solves
problems you know for the entirety of humanity
and that's really exciting and i think you know
when you see that happening in your city when you
see your city transforming when you realize
your city's on the forefront like you said
of innovation the forefront of the future you
know that you're creating an ecosystem and an
economy that not only serves my generation but
serves my children and my unborn grandchildren
it's such a pleasure to be here and be part of
the energy and to feel it all but speaking of
being on the forefront of innovation this
really started kind of about a year ago
because you made that infamous tweet somebody
asked um you know can we make miami like silicon
valley and you said how can i help so talk me
through this why did you want to help and what is
it really that you see for miami that you wanted
to change well we had really been trying for 10
years to create this technological ecosystem the
reason why is because we know that the economy
of the future is going to be driven by technology
whether we like technology or we don't no matter
what party you're from no matter what issues you
may think that that exists in technology it's it's
it's a reality and it's a reality that we could
either as a city we can run from or we can embrace
and so we've decided to embrace it because we know
that's a pathway to prosperity for our citizens
we know that's going to create high-paying
jobs in our community and it's already doing it
so what happened was we had been building this
economy sort of slowly like a small business you
know bootstrapped with friends and family money
and then all of a sudden on december 4th we had
this sort of ipo moment where we we shot like a
rocket to the moon and the kpi since then are off
the charts we're number one in the nation in tech
job growth number one in the nation in tech job
migration according to pitchbook uh we went up uh
like billions of dollars in vc money from one year
to the next i think it was a 50 growth in one year
uh we've we've brought like a trillion dollars of
assets under management companies to the city of
miami and and created thousands of high-paying
jobs so we've done that all in one year which just
goes to show how disruptive this world is and how
you know a city that maybe wasn't talked about in
tech is now the city that's most talked about in
tech absolutely you guys are leading now when it
comes to cryptocurrency so let's go into all of
that i think what's unique about you as a mayor is
that i feel you really understand and really grasp
the frustration that people in the cryptocurrency
community have with the traditional financial
system so from your perspective what would you say
some of the key issues is that cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin are actually solving well you i think
you articulate very well which is the fact that in
a modern day world if you have money in a
bank account you're not earning any interest
and we're an incredibly inflationary uh economy
not just in the us but across the world and so
you're literally losing purchasing power every
single day that your money is sitting idle
and so that means that you have to look at options
and what are the options that you have and i think
one of the things that people don't talk enough
about is with bitcoin the market has already
taken a look at bitcoin looked at its fundamentals
and priced it against the dollar whether it's 60
000 or whether it's 50 000 it still takes 50 000
us dollars to buy one bitcoin so the market has
it created a tremendous amount of confidence
in that system which is a system that cannot
be manipulated by human beings and it's a system
that's open and transparent that is incredibly
powerful and so you know i know that people that
don't like bitcoin what i call the haters right
they will point to the volatility of bitcoin
and my view of it is you know i'm not a day
trader i'm not here trying to trying to trade
up and down based on a price one day or another
i'm holding a currency or an asset or a digital
asset because of its fundamentals and because
of where i think it's going to go and i think
when you look at its performance uh over time
it's certainly outperformed inflation and
certainly outperformed so many other assets i'm
sure that i don't think there's many asset classes
that have outperformed bitcoin and so it's it's
it's really just a phenomenon like you see these
technological phenomenas when we went from trading
marbles to gold from gold to you know dollars
backed by gold to dollars not backed by gold and
fiat currencies it's just another evolution in the
way that we as human beings are going to transact
business and you mentioned inflation there and we
were told um by the by the federal reserve that
inflation is transitory that's kind of the the
idea and the sentiment but it's clearly not the
case and so there seems to be a lot of hostility
um from the senate from the government from all
sorts of institutions um towards cryptocurrency so
how do you see the the two the traditional system
and cryptocurrencies working alongside each other
do you think that's possible you know to answer
the first question i think the federal government
i think has already started to walk back the idea
that it's transitory you know you have um you
know a ton of money which has been put into the
circulation or in the money supply through excess
government spending and then you have supply chain
shortages uh which are conspiring to create this
sort of perfect storm and i think a lot of people
believe that the cpi is under reporting inflation
i think cpi is only at six percent uh people when
you consider housing costs and other things that
may not be in the basket of goods to the cpi
think it's significantly higher so i think
that's that's that's a big part of it
and what was the second question i forgot oh
okay so the second part of the question is
how do you see the two systems working alongside
each other given the hostility that we have seen
you know i think right now they're working
alongside of each other but i think that
there's a real possibility a real possibility
that one can completely disrupt the other one and
and i think obviously crypto disrupting sort of
the fiat legacy system right that you would say i
think what you might see that disruption uh happen
faster is in areas of hyperinflation like we're
seeing a lot of inflation in the us but frankly
the u.s dollar is still you know considered to
be you know an important currency but when you
look at central america south america and even
africa you're looking at areas that are ripe for
disruption where people could have more confidence
potentially trading satoshis as opposed to
whatever the currency of their of their country
is and they can do it in a peer-to-peer format and
and if they can get out of the control structure
of what government tries to do um then i think
we can see not only bitcoin being something that
metamorphosis from store value into a currency
but we can see it as a liberating force and that's
something that gets me really excited when i think
about the landscape of what the future of our
world can look like but given how disruptive you
imagine it's going to be how did your colleagues
take to your new innovative stance and how did
you basically convince them you know my colleagues
have been very supportive a lot of them by the way
in sort of my parents generation and you know some
of them said like hey we trust you like we trust
you to do this so i think that's been part of it
then the our other part of it is the results have
been good right like when you know when you see
uh someone innovating and things work out you you
create confidence right you create credibility and
i think they've seen that in me they've seen you
know the virality of what this moment has created
for miami we've become a cr you know i think we're
the crypto capital of the world so we brought
thank you we brought uh ftx here they did a
200 million dollar naming deal blockchain.com
located headquarters here etoro israeli uh
exchange located at headquarters here xbto
and we brought the bitcoin conference from la 50
000 attendees we're gonna do it again next april
so we have i think change the center of gravity
uh uh you know from some of the mega markets to
what i can what i call as the epicenter of capital
or the capital of capital where we're right in the
middle of europe the middle east you know uh new
york south america and the silicon valley no one
of those mega markets is closer to each other than
they are to miami and so i think that uh puts us
in a unique position to sort of metamorphosize and
graduate from being the same you know the capital
of latin america to being the epicenter of capital
this is i'm just in awe of what you're doing it's
so refreshing to hear maya speak like this and
obviously you're taking your salary and bitcoin
that is absolutely wild so why firstly um how from
a practical standpoint and obviously are you not
concerned about the volatility i'm not and so the
why and how the why is because you know we have to
keep innovating we have to always stay ahead of
the curve we have to sort of set the narrative
the how's simple we use an app called strike which
is really easy to use and anyone can use it though
do am i afraid of volatility the answer is no and
the reason why is because and i have to say in
full disclosure that my mayoral salary is not my
only salary so as a mayor in miami-dade accounting
most of the mayors have outside income i have
a you know a sort of private sector life and so
it's not my full income and so you know i i don't
necessarily think that someone should necessarily
put their full income in it but i do think you
know something that is reasonable in terms of what
they want to invest they want to diversify their
portfolio they want to save money in a particular
asset a digital asset like bitcoin you know that's
something that i feel comfortable with and so you
also have to lead by example in life you know uh
and i think uh that creates a level of excitement
you know when i was the first person uh first
elected official in america to get covered
you know when i did a diary uh it made people
feel at ease because they saw me dealing with it
and struggling with it in a very public way and
so i think that uh that taught me that you know
transparency and and putting yourself out there
is something can be very rewarding i think it's
really rewarding and i think people actually pick
that up um from you um yeah you know it instills
more confidence in miami and everything that you
say but of course that is the goal it's a great
it's it's working so there's also miami coin so
that is also crazy talk to me about miami coin
and how it works and also where the value of
it comes from sure so miami coin is a bitcoin
based uh technology right and the reason why is
because it's created out of the stacks blockchain
which hashes onto the bitcoin blockchain obviously
we all know the bitcoin blockchain is the most
decentralized and secure blockchain on the planet
and so there's an interaction between bitcoin
stocks and then this coin that was created through
stacks which is essentially a smart contract
uh which is miami coin and miami coin what it
does which is similar and different with bitcoin
in bitcoin when you mine a bitcoin the miner gets
100 percent of the revenue as well they should
they're the ones that they're the authenticating
mechanism for this network in miami coin 30
of the mining revenue goes into a digital wallet
for miami and so for the city whatever the city it
is whether it's miami new york or whatever they've
already established new york corn so uh we thought
you know if it generates three million or
five million dollars in a year that'd be
super successful it's generated over
20 million dollars in four months so
the the you know the the fact that we have created
a brand has gotten people to invest and to and to
and and to believe in something like miami coin
and where its value is going to be and i think
similar to you know bitcoin i do think there will
be massive utility uh models into 2022 i think
if 2020 thing i think is the year of the
mainstreaming i think 2022 will be the year of
utility can you give us some examples of utility
for miami coin sure uh one of the things that
i would say is you know and i think this is the
same for bitcoin we want to get to a point where
you can go in and buy a snickers with bitcoin
right like who when is that moment gonna happen
and so i think you know for miami coin not too
dissimilar from bitcoin if it's liquid which it
is you know you can go into a restaurant you can
you can get a meal in a miami restaurant maybe
you get a discount for using a miami coin and so
i've had a lot of people come to me with you know
utility ideas and how they can collaborate with
miami coin um and so we're going to be unveiling
some of those next year hopefully and so you mine
it an individual just becomes a miner and they
they get 70 of the of the profits right so in in
bitcoin in the bitcoin mining world you get 100 of
profits you mine something right and the offshoot
of that mining if you solve the mathematical
problem to authenticate the the transaction you
get 100 in the case of miami coin you get 70
and the 30 of what is essentially the pot goes uh
to the cities in a digital wallet so i read at one
point you guys were offering or not you but miami
coin the network was offering 430 apy i think it's
now around just over 100 apy how does that work
talk to me about how that's even possible so
the way it works is it depends on how people are
investing in the coin so it's a totally different
uh a proof mechanism than than bitcoin the proof
mechanism bitcoin of course is proof of work
so it and it's based on splitting from satoshi's
formula in the case of miami coin you're actually
pledging coins and so the derivative of that
pledge is the mining revenue and so that's why
it can be a higher yield than but the yield has
gone down which is is understandable and expected
uh it's not going to always be 400 everyone
would would do that if that were the case
and so that that's coming back down to earth
but i still think it's an attractive proposition
and we're going to stake our miami coin revenue
which is in is in stacks to hopefully create a
bitcoin yield so we can actually give a bitcoin
yield to all of our residents in the city at
least all the ones that sign up yeah so two things
firstly it doesn't matter you know if it's gone
from 400 to 100 it's better than negative interest
rates which we see across europe yeah exactly so
talk to me about that bitcoin dividend how does
that work how often is it paid out and also can
anybody get involved so for example i'm obviously
not a us citizen but i'm trying to be a resident
in 2022. when can i get my bitcoin dividend
yeah you got to be in miami i will make that so
there you go so the way it's going to be is you
know first we have to we have to create what i
call the universe right so who is in miami how do
you define me i mean anybody can define themselves
ma'am and you can be in nebraska and say i'm a
miami so we had to come up with the universe and i
think the universe that we're we're thinking of is
people who are registered voters in miami in the
city of miami so that's someone who who we can we
can verify we can define and we know that they're
engaged in some sort of civic endeavor which
hopefully is voting right and it also promotes
a civic endeavor which is voting and so that's
that's part of it the second part is is then we
would we would offer them hopefully an array of
digital wallets and we're working with some big
exchanges i can't say yeah because it would ruin
the surprise right that would ex that would put
uh miami coin on their uh digital um you know
on their uh on their exchanges and would also
offer a digital wallet for our residents to be
able to receive the dividend in uh bitcoin and
so then the third thing is how often will we do it
i think we would like to set it up in a quarterly
fashion because i think that you know we're going
to be constantly doing it we want to do it sort of
you know make it the management cost a reasonable
and the sort of logistics of it reasonable so i
think that's what we're looking at and we're you
know we're doing this for the first time so we're
sort of inventing the wheel if you will yeah
absolutely and you've actually been called by
a lot of tech entrepreneurs i'm the ceo of miami
which i think is brilliant um given that you're
trying to recruit as much talent to the city as
possible and we've seen um i think he's there now
the mayor-elect eric adams of um new york so is
there a competition going on there to i don't know
see who could become the leading cryptocurrency
city well i am technically the ceo of the city
uh in the charter i'm the chief executive officer
but you know the mayor and i have a friendship you
know and we've developed a friendship and and you
know for us it's about we are we're the ones that
are like like you said we're not only the chief
executive officers we're chief marketers of our
city you know we want to present the best image
for our city we want to give our residents the
best chance to be successful into the future
and so when you talk about you know new york
obviously their mayor is going to be championing
initiatives that he thinks are going to put their
city forward and i think the fact that we've
been able to have this sort of fun back and forth
is a really positive thing for both of our cities
but more importantly it's a positive thing for
america because it means that the our country is
maintaining itself on the forefront of innovation
which is not what china's doing that's shutting
down bitcoin mining and shutting down bitcoin
we're taking advantage of the innovation that
other countries are maybe not taken advantage of
and so in terms of miami then where do you see
it in the next five to ten years you know like
i said i've been playing with this concept
of our metamorphosis right i think we're in
a generational inflection point in the history
of not just our country but the world and i
think miami is well positioned to come out
of that disruptive era and that generational
opportunity as one of the most significant
cities in the world and i think part of it
is our geolocation part of it is our attitude and
our perspective of innovation um and you know and
part of it is our you know two years like you said
our entrepreneurial work ethic spirit that's going
to be combined with people coming from the outside
and capital coming from the outside that's going
to create this incredible mix that will have
a two to five to seven year horizon as as we
invest in ourselves and see that the companies
that are produced now today uh are exiting in
two and five and seven years mayor suarez i want
to thank you so much it's been such a pleasure
speaking with you um keep doing what you're doing
i'm loving it i can't wait to move here um and i
really appreciate everything that you're creating
we can't wait for you to be a bitcoin dividend
recipient thank you so much guys thank you so much
for watching thank you to exodus for sponsoring
this and please don't forget to subscribe
and hit like so you never miss a video you